ブーブーって
三小田数えを1箱になぁ本のマッチが入ってるからな
なんぼなんだろう
34は適当だな34てどういうことから見てる約100本でしょ
12個以上3つで100本の1箱400かけるそれがズっ子様膳もんなぁハッチバッ
を4000本全部しましたオギャー持ってしまった松葉はこうすると思いますとこう
ねっ
はっ
この金を使わな
で魂抜けマッチ棒4000本を一気に燃やすとどれくらいの火力になるかというのを
実験しようと思います
子は上で今回こちらで坊主準備しました浦氏の先端に街を4000本をつけていき
ましょうよ
待ったこれめんどいわああ
ブーブーですこれを繰り返していきます
ッパああ
選考にしておきましょう戦後にしております多分これね多分
艦これ4000戸であったらちょっと嫌な予感って言う寄せごったをポンと分爆破物
言ってるんでそちらで前後でいきましょうはいこんな感じだ
4前ない快適で打ち完成しました4000庵棟だ
家が吹き飛んで所止めて抹茶ぽ1000個付けましたこんな感じでございますさあ問題
はここからがこの魔壺生後どのように転化するかと言いますと
抹茶を操るの巨大な槍を準備しましたこの安いるよ発火しなさそうな鏡とかにくっつけ
ていきますこれは萌えるよねー
完璧な大奇橋キャンパーツールこの痩せるこういう感じが張っていきますはいてあげて
こんな感じでございますうやーいいんじゃないですか敗1分けで打っちゃうよちぼ専門
棟や3が完成しました皆さん大変を致しますマッチ棒1000本の火力試してみ
ましょう
忍具財けどありげだな思えないけど
様子ぜぃ
car
ああああああ
わー
ないと家ではありませんよ
ban
実際こんなが強いと危ないのでいつも水を準備しました
よしバッチリじゃないでしょうかじゃあさっそく天かすいますとこれ
マッチ棒1000本の火力だねばいこう
やらじゃないよまって扱いなんか未遂たくねーわ
聞くがー free to 1
toranoana
car
ローザヤッホー
すげー生き返っ
ピケットの選んだねえっぐちょ号2010時にオリンピック外れ社長は応援します
ああああああ
me
ni
一瞬成果だってねうん菓子がもんパーんだったんで
いやースゴイねこれは四世もいけるんじゃないですかちょっと行けさデマッターちゃる
んでしょうと思いますあのちょっと危ないずでなるべくマネしないでくださいもしどう
してもしたっていう君多くお父さんお母さん一緒にやりましょうこのなんだろう
花火してもいい場所とかねぱな人がしてもいい安全な場所でやってみてください
ん
はーはっはっは